so like these lights right
I bought them just the way that they are
flub they've got chips in them they've
got cracks in them they've got like
little brush marks that I can't seem to
clean away but I mean they're gorgeous
these lights kind of connect to that
journey in the sense that they're not
perfect but they do exactly what I need
them to do and so I collect old things
and try to make them new again because I
think it's part of loving and embracing
your past but still seeing how beautiful
those things can be for your future okay
so my name is Michelle I am from Detroit
originally and I live in Chicago what
else did you want me to tell you I
didn't have debt until I went away to
college so I was lucky and that I got a
lot of support to go to college but I
ultimately did have to take out a small
amount of student loans but then you
know like after I graduated I was quote
unquote successful so I was supposed to
be living the dream so I acquired more
debt and more debt and more debt so I
think it just began to snowball from
there my father always said god bless
the child who has its own so my thing
was if I want it then I need to own it
myself I need to have it myself but I
also had a very strong sense of I guess
what Dave would call stuff entitlement
like I needed to reward myself for all
the good things that I've ever done so
shopping is my day
but I bought a condo before I got into
you and I thought I've got this condo
and I can't furnish it unless I use a
credit card like I just didn't want to
do that so I guess you could say that
was my turning point I read the book and
then I also start listening to the radio
show so the radio show was super
impactful to me and my journey because I
hear these families making less money
than I made alone and I think I'm
thinking to myself why is this so hard
for me if it's so easy for them they
have four or five miles to feed and it's
just me and I don't eat that much I
don't think and first maybe two or three
credit cards were very small was very
easy
sounds like others this is a piece of
cake I can do this and I cut those cards
up but I had two cards that had large
credit lines thank you
large limits so if I cut them up and
close these accounts I'm gonna do 80% of
what Dave tells me and the 20% means I'm
not cutting nice cards up before you
know it it goes from being paid off to
being edits limit and so the first time
it happened I said to myself okay you're
human it's okay to make mistakes and I
took the cards and instead of carrying
them with me I put them in a drawer in
my bedroom
of course in charge the cards back up
again for the third time I don't think
it really hit me until I paid off my
student loans I could have been out of
debt so much earlier had I just cut the
cards up so once I got like extremely
frustrated I went ahead I cut the cards
up I closed the accounts which was a
little unnerving but after I paid off my
my last big debt which was my student
loans and saw how quickly I saved my
baby step number three it gave me a
sense of relief a big sense of relief
being debt-free makes me super confident
and knowing my value in my work and what
I what I can contribute and what I'm not
willing to take I will tell you that I'm
at a point in my career where I'm a
little brazen and I think I feel that
way because at the end of the day if I
lose my job tomorrow I'm gonna be okay
so I got my first tattoo last weekend
I've got to show you guys it says
persevere on my arm and the reason I got
this tattoo is because it means
something to me and I want to be able to
see it every day I want to be able to
see it to remind myself that anything I
put my mind to I can do it I want to
remind myself that I paid off one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars and
27 months I want to remind myself that
it was not easy
just like getting this tattoo was not
easy it was very hard even when I
thought I was going to tell the lady to
stop once she did the me I allowed her
to keep going
and that was you know kind of what my
financial journey was right it was these
moments where I thought I wasn't going
to be able to go and I had to start all
over again I've been paying off my
credit cards three times but I think
everybody can persevere my advice to
anybody who wants to become debt-free or
who wants to just accomplish any big
goal in life is to just take it in small
digestible bites and know that it's not
always going to be easy you know that
you may have to persevere and know that
at the end on the other side you will
come out stronger and better for having
going through it and you know big debt
free is my testament to that
[Music]
[Music]